hello reject nation
Greg Alba here sammy gonzales theme
excellence who's from double toast calm
he's gonna help me catch up on some
movie trailers that came out we're gonna
just do this in one giant video so you
don't have to get multiple uploads
they're all seem like they're probably
in similar genres anyway so it's all
linked how you doing Sam I'm doing good
I have no idea what we're watching
neither do I actually except that
they're all r-rated films
we got dark crimes American animals hot
summer nights dark crimes on IMDB this
is slated as a 2016 film so maybe it's
just beginning push back a lot for
specific reasons so it's actually a Jim
Carrey thriller movie and he's making
paintings now yeah all over Twitter and
it's not the president which who would
have thought Jim Carrey one day would
piss off the president who wouldn't [ __ ]
it will be so sensitive to Jim Carrey's
paintings one day rated R for strong and
disturbing though including rape graphic
nudity and language Saban films though
Power Rangers yeah
[Music]
okay here
yeah no no I don't from the case we
can't see doing an accent I think so
the revenant we have a suspect it crime
right there this guy's victim's body at
the modulus of someone choked to death
using a fisherman's knot it's basic
instinct but you get too close
that's good this case is all I have left
you know these these quotes are not
actually selling me honey not at all Oh
we strangle the man what makes you think
the murder is an Avenue
okay dark rhymes I'm vexed you know I I
think this guy recommended a lot because
people really like this trailer I don't
have faith in doing some creative things
with them looking into the camera and
like addressing anything for ya point of
view type of thing they're doing some
editing stuff yeah interesting I guess
it seems like a wannabe Fincher slash
who's the guy who did like the original
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo oh oh this
is where the snowman vibes like and then
there has to be a reason why this was
pushed back from 26 yeah you must not
have faith in it something with the
subject matter of like the women being
on leashes or something yeah that might
be relevant saying that that's relevant
necessarily but that there might be an
element to that that might feed into
irrelevant the plotline of the author
who like wrote his own crimes yeah this
seems like Basic Instinct territory and
then I get over these quotes Carrie
throws himself into the role he did that
with the mask yeah he does that's what
he's jobless Carey acted in this
movements like saying Christian Bale
threw himself into the role of
Terminator Salvation did a good job
impressive acting ensemble yeah so I was
like oceans gains more Martin's clothes
Gus yeah who are these people like
saying they got a good cast assembly the
unique parts to me were some of the cool
stylish editing but I couldn't tell that
was part of the trailer or if that was
the actual movie cuz that stuff looked
really appealing to me was like when it
gets like really weird and a little
hypnotic that stuff is kind of cool but
the rest of it kind of feels like a
cliche crime thriller to be honest when
I hate the title yeah I hate the title
but at the same time I think they're
doing what a lot of B movies do and they
or like C movies even were they like
yeah there's rape involved and it's real
gravity and violent against women and
they use that as the hook this kind of
seems like a higher class
version of that even though it's still
really cheap and dirty and yeah it's
almost exploited if it's not it's not
shown in a way that has any sort of
motivation or any deeper meaning behind
like oh this is gonna shock you and it's
dark and it's Jim Carrey the osseous
looks generic there's some cool
cinematography to them but it also feels
like it's trying to be like other movies
this isn't the kind of thing I'm
watching Jim Carrey going comedian Jim
Carrey like I'm not at this point I
could buy him in a serious role it's
just the film itself too honest it
doesn't look as appealing as people
probably want the producer of the
revenue is not the really mean nothing
when people say from the studios that
are good all movies are bad anyway hey
if we haven't lost you yet another
trailer yes we hope your movies are
featured in this it's a good thing we
saw off for that one let's we want to
American Hannah oh wait oh you started
rolling yeah we pickin no sticking my
nose man I was like nose hairs you know
come on God thank you for addressing me
by my Christian it's God Greg Elba
American animals this stars Evan Peters
who is Quicksilver and from American
Horror Story did a JK Rowling write this
American you know I love all these
movies that have the word American in it
and they're always about some like
greedy criminal also criminal if you
really think about it you never hear
American something and you're like ah
this is about someone who's a good
person Captain America no but if it was
American captain let's check this one
out
radar for language throughout some drug
use and brief crude sexual material I
can go for brief movie pass Avengers Wow
if they have their own thing now I love
Evan Peters by the way I really do hope
you feel like you're waiting for
something to happen it pains me to see
you embarrass your father but you don't
know what it is
frat boys you're in oh you're right that
thing that could make your life special
oh you're out
well your app how can I tell you manner
amount without you telling you the first
thing about one of my being around maybe
something dangerous very exciting what
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
let's do this okay this is not based on
a true story this actually happened the
IMDB description says four young men
mistake their lives for a movie and a
tenth one of the most audacious heist in
US history is this a movie about them
actually doing a heist that actually
happened
I don't know this a true crime at the
same time and one of the quotes besides
that the tag lines and the words this is
confusing me I think one of those by the
Financial Times I was like I don't think
they're the best movie besides that
confusing me I feel like there's a lot
of style and the performances are
something I am personally gravitated
towards I don't know how you feel but
this is something that I think I can get
on board with you can I can get on board
with this could be no this is probably
going to be bad you see in this because
here's the thing but you know name guys
I don't know what the premises I don't
know how this is different than in
another heist movie because they're
telling me not a movie it actually
happened if you say is it our version of
pain and gain honestly any gain is a
pretty good movie in its own right I
personally like that too I feel like
this could be better than like David
Fincher meets pain engaged like these
guys seem like actually psychotic I
guess but they seem more clueless and
weird to me I'll just put out that weird
like white privilige vibes from this man
like oh yeah total like you know like I
want something a meaning in my life
they're all a bunch of frat bros and
they're gonna go steal a flamingos
paintings because they're order they
want a couple million dollars like where
are they gonna sell this I'm already
funny things weren't like you already
make me question this because you're
spending so long on it building it up
are you in or you out I'm out I think
the trailer could be better at
communicating what this movies actually
about but that's also kind of why I've
drawn to it it must be one of those
things that's a little too complicated
to properly communicate in a trailer
usually those kind of indie films I tend
to enjoy for some reason right and I
just really like Evan Peters along why I
love him on American Horror Story in
some ways I feel like he could be the
next Johnny Depp the young Johnny Depp
yeah not today's Johnny and I like a
cool heist movie it's a little confusing
on is this even really
happening or is this in their
imagination it's kind of confusing never
the style is cinematography and the
seems like there's a weird frantic
kinetic energy about it yeah I'm drawn
to there's things about an appeal - does
that mean I'm actually gonna take my
time out of the day to go and watch this
at a theatre yeah I don't know and I
feel the same things that you feel about
I feel that that helping energy that
this is key there's a dog odd like a
two-legged dog walking in there's weird
things happening I don't know if they're
weird for the sake of being weird or if
they're actually building to something
or or trying to create something unique
it is unique
maybe a little pretentious yeah it's
like unique doesn't always mean good so
I feel you on that I think the trailer
could have done a better job of
communicating what this movie actually
is yeah and I like weird [ __ ] like you
know give me some of this weird and kind
of present in a way that's like oh I can
wrap my head around instead of
contradicting yourself yeah but I was
like this is not a true story but it
totally hat was like everything I watch
was like you make me question something
that sounds as absurd as this I don't
want to watch it okay that's it don't
don't get me questioning you before
you hook me well then I think we should
move on to a company that is known to do
weird movies that are usually pretty
good and that is a 24s hot summer nights
a 24 stars
Timothy Shanna mais French who was and
call me by your name and Lady Bird and
he is sexy he was on the cover of GQ
magazine not long ago he is a very sexy
man so it was I one time hey Sammy
you're someone's Jesus Christ yes Hannah
because you are God a 24 in the DirecTV
there you go those are the two best
companies
it's been in the symbol with unity God
sending me away for the summer
what a cliche self-aware cliche nobody
talks like that
[Music]
nice I kind of move it
whoa so peach I guess you got lucky
[Music]
no I wouldn't want that
what would you say if I said I wanted to
start so we what's this one that's as if
more people bought these my life will be
a lot easier we should sell lower those
the problem is video and dime bags
teenagers we need customers who buy in
bulk you didn't know how to use the bomb
and now you're trying to tell me how to
flip we'd have something even looking
for pops Josh a good question cops can't
do that
sit down hey play something celebratory
[Music]
Thomasson Shane here's soever you came
three nights turn around and sleepless
when you are the cool times you know
it's gonna tear you apart can't hold on
everything I think some things yeah and
I hope you're been a bigger
[Music]
okay well I think we watch these
trailers in the right order
that's how you do weird stuff yeah and
it makes sense it makes sense you get a
plot you get a character even though the
tones shift crazy at me you still go
with it because Timothy Xiaomei he's
awesome and they're all good yeah he's
very good and in this it hasn't stopped
streaky's guys this guy just needs to
stop having terrible summers and that's
the thing it's like breaking bad but for
college kids like we'd try to sell in
bulk so we're gonna do in the cartel
cartel a whole bunch of white people in
all three of these this looks like an 8
24 film yeah in terms of like it I like
its kind of yellow tint and it has 70
this like 70 some white cinematography
like it because nowadays this one have
we said that Jesse Jackson 88 hats
pretty cool it is that's gonna be a hat
that people buy now this seems like an 8
24 spin on a typical story of young
white dude who gets in blue just wants
to have more in his life falls in love
with a girl gets involved in drugs
things started going great and like the
first half of this movie makes a lot of
money gets involved with the wrong
people a lot of movies do that blow
American what ever made any American
something all in bed was a rise and fall
out of the greed but then he learns that
the other day all he needs is friendship
or something loses all the money it's a
coming-of-age story for weed we go to
jail like most other coat coat
like they'd go to jail and that being in
the movie it's kind of taken one of
those biopic tales but it seems like
contained in a specific time frame yeah
yeah as opposed to a lot of those other
films that have a similar plot it's like
this family 10 to 15 years of their life
or even more and then they fall in the
end and I'm like this seems like the
kind of movie where he could maybe even
die but yeah it would be totally makes
sense at least of what they're setting
up right yeah cuz also just a love story
at the end of the day you know they're
taking polaroid pictures of him smoking
joint yes I love the concept of he's
just an outcast and no one likes him
until he starts becoming a STONER
definitely do mom sorry mom
Sammy's the last half of this movie was
gonna get dark
Timothy shale amazing it has something
really unique about him yeah where he
can play these kind of like nerdy
introverted dudes who are also cool with
the deep voice of Michael Cera and then
all the benefits of a good actor he
doesn't have that first look we were
like oh he's a sexy guy but he starts
like performing and stuff yeah I can see
why women find this guy so much yeah
hands in his pockets yeah I look at sexy
as hell right damn look at this guy a
cool man and will gotta love snow will I
figure a name yeah well yeah shredder
and Tom and Thomas Jane of course Jane
doing another character piece here I
like how each one of these was about
crime watch and they all had we had like
flaws would both like they were all all
crimes done by wise people this world
where we're all bitching about diversity
we see three crime movies about white
dudes alright guys well Sammy thanks for
helping me catch up with these traders
for having me catch up and helping you
with these trailers you can subscribe to
the region I'm good okay click that
notification but also subscribe buttons
mean something check us out on patreon a
lot of goodies over there sammy gonzales
is the MECs Alliance on instagram and
twitter and he's with double toast accom
go subscribe soundcloud exteriorly 9 a
month and you can get all sorts of
toasty goodness all over your body John
does John does and you should too
I'm waiting for he uses his account
that's why I use his like hell on his
computer see you guys